えっと あの 何回もお話を聞いていらっしゃる方々もいらっしゃるし
今日初めて参加なさっている方々もいらっしゃるし
とにかくこの五つのこの授業では
講義では あの 釈迦さんの教えっていうのを紹介という形であの
まあちょっとお話しさせていただきます
あまり難しいことはできるだけあの喋らないで置いておきます
ですから あの すごく あの
厳密にこの難しいことという感じではなくて
あの まあ気楽に聞いてみてください
で いろんなことを厳密に説明欲しいということがございますから
あの話の途中でいつでも構いませんだから
あの さっさとあの質問してください
いつでも質問した方がよろしいんです
今日初めの定義は あのあの
まあいわゆる根本仏教というお釈迦様の教えと宗教というあの二つのタイトルなんですね
まあ違いはあるかないかということで
で なんで釈迦の教えと宗教っていう関係がありますかというと
やっぱりまあ釈迦の教えは仏教という名前で
世の中で宗教としてあのずっと二千五百年間信じてきたんですね
ですから 世の中のあのとても古い宗教の一つなんですね
で まあ古い宗教といえば
あのユダヤ教があってね
ヨーロッパの方で また一番世の中で古いっていうのは
このイランにあったこのゾロアスター教というね
宗教あります それすごく古いんです
それからインドにはこの昔
このヒンドゥー教の元ですか
あのもうありましたけど
ヒンドゥー教は古くないんだけど
今今現在インドインドにあるヒンドゥー教というのは
それはすごい古い あの他の宗教から出てきているものだから
それも結構古いものなんですね
で まあそれなりに古いんですけど
仏教はまあまあそれよりは若いんだけど
二千五百年間は宗教として実践して信じてきたものなんです
で でも仏教ではこのもう一つ特色があるんです
お釈迦様が教え始めたその時からも
徹底的にこの世界宗教として教えてきたんです
人類に説きますと で すごい
この 何と言いますか 幅が広かったんですね
人類っていうのは 今我々は皆様に理解できるように言いますけど
お釈迦様は人類ってことを使ってないんです
人々と人間と デーヴァマヌッスって二つの言葉を使うんです
デーヴァという言葉で
デーヴァというのは神々ということで
マヌッサという言葉がありまして
マヌッサっていうのは人間という言葉なんですね
デーヴァマヌッサなんていう言葉使ってるんで
デーヴァとの神々にも教えますと
人間にも教えますと この道は神々にも通用するて
人間にも通用するんだという立場から始まるんですね
そこからもうなんかドンと宗教となんかちょっと違うんじゃないんでしょうかね
宗教っていうのは神という概念があって
それにすがったり拝んだり
頼ったり 神様が言うことを信じたり
実行したりする そういう上下関係なんですね
いきなりお釈迦様は神々にも教えてあげると
始めちゃうんだから なんかちょっとなんかちょっと態度がな
ちょっと大きすぎじゃないかなとは思うかもしれません
でもそこが違うところなんですね
そこでなんで神々と人間入ったんですかというと
この二つがいくらか精神的に優れていて
物事を理解できて まあ知識人ではないかとというふうな考え方なんですね
それから仏教では 生命のことを喋る場合はすべての生命を扱っちゃうんです
微生物まで 例えば慈悲の心
すべてのさ それで仏教で言ってるんですね
その場を目に見えない微生物にさえ優しい心そくれなさいと
その時は生命はすべて入ります
神々にも慈悲をするんです
それまた仏教と他の宗教の違うところなんですね
で 他の宗教見れば 人間
我々は人間同士でお互いに助け合って
優しい心で生活しましょうと
この社会の人間の間での慈悲を教えてるんですね
愛ですね で ヒンドゥー教
仏教になってくると 人間だけじゃなくて
まあ動物やら他の生命も入っちゃうんですね
でも仏教だけなっちゃうと
変調ごとまた一飛んじゃって
神々も全部まとめてみんな幸福でありますようにと
なんかまたそこ見たっても
ちょっと態度がまあなんか大きすぎなんじゃないかなと思うかもしれません
そこで 慈悲を実践する場合
慈悲っていうのは仏教の言葉で
皆様が理解できないならば
他の宗教でこの愛という言葉で使っている
ヒンドゥー教でプレマですね LOVE
という言葉で まあなんとなく似ている概念なんですね
まあそれぐらいで理解しておいてください
そこで慈悲の場合は 神々も入っちゃって
神々よりもっと上の存在があるならば
それも入っちゃって すべての存在をまとめて慈悲を実践すると
教える場合は ある部分を排除して
神々と人間だけにしちゃうんですね
あれは何でしょうかと
例えば慈悲をする場合は
ゴキブリにもアリにも
もう目に見えない微生物に慈悲をするんだったら
なんでお釈迦様の教えだけ
教えもそんなみんなにネズミにも教えたくないんですかとかね
うちの猫にもなんで教えてやり悪いんですかということ出てくるかもしれませんね
慈悲だからと で その時は
また仏教の違うところ見えてくるんですね
で 仏教は理解するために実践するために
一つ条件があるんです
みんなにできるわけじゃないんです
いくらすべての生命にといっても
その条件というのは理性的にやることなんですね
理性的で知識的であること
知恵があること いわゆる自由に物事を考えられますかと
思考の自由 この思考の自由というのは法律的なものじゃないんです
生きている者として 我々に思考の自由があるかないかといえば
やっぱり自由なんですね
人間というのは 物事にはもう考えとなれば考えられるんですね
その能力は神々にもあるんです
ですから この二人 二つの生命にはもう教えられるんだと
で うちの猫ちゃんにも仏教を教えたってもいいんだけど
まず人間の言葉はわからないし
思考の自由はないんですね
ですから無理なんですね
それは猫ちゃんに対して慈悲がないということじゃなくて
まあ無理だから無理させる必要はないんです
それだけのことです そこでまた三番目の仏教
仏教の特色 お分かりになるでしょう
仏教という宗教には やっぱり思考の自由
理性というものが必要なんです
ある本を書かれた人がこの理性の揺らぎとかなんとかって本を書いちゃって
宗教に入っちゃうと理性はもう関係なくなっちゃいますって言うんだけど
あれとは違うんです ちゃんとした理性が必要なんです
仏教には ですから 宗教とは違うというふうに言えるんですね
なんでということというと
この大体この 私はこのある特別な宗教を批判しようということではなくて
ちょっと比べてみたいだけなんですね
大体人間の心の中で 宗教で言った途端
信じるもの 頼るものという感じが来るんですね
もうなんとか助けてくださいと
[咳]いわゆる自分の
何て言いますか わかりやすく言えば自分の権利を放棄して
任すんですね 身を 宗教というものに
大体そういう特色はなんとなくあるんですね
仏教ではそこの逆なんです
反対なんです 仏教というのは
お釈迦様の教えでは あの仏教はそれからいろんな枝分かれになっちゃって
いろんな仏教ありますよ
そこはまた他の宗教と似ていますけど
釈迦さん自身がおっしゃったもの
純粋におっしゃったものはもう頼るなという言葉から出てくるんですね
自立しなさいと 頼ってはいけませんと
ですから  そこら辺で この宗教の一番大事な特色が仏教ではないんです
いわゆる拝んで頼ってみて
あの 何て言いますか 自分
自分の全部放棄をして
放棄して 自分を投げ捨てて
何か恩恵を受けると まあ同じ宗教の中から例を出すならば
他の宗教から例を出しちゃって怒られるかもしれませんだけど
例えば仏教の一部がありまして
この浄土系統のね 浄土真宗とかいろいろありますね
そこで日蓮上人なんか言ってるのは
もう自分という気持ちさえも捨てちゃって
もう南無阿弥陀仏と唱えなさいということなんですね
それをどこまで言ってますかと
南無阿弥陀仏であなたが唱えるんじゃないんだと
それは阿弥陀仏が唱えさせているんだと
そこまで自己放棄ということをおっしゃってるんですね
私は南無阿弥陀仏と言ってるんじゃなくて
阿弥陀様が南無阿弥陀仏と言わされてるんだと
それぐらい自分の意思というものを置いておくと
で それの全く正反対の立場が仏教なら自分で責任取れと
ですから なんか怖そうな宗教なんですね
頼った方が安全で楽なんですけどね
助けてちょうだいと その方が楽でしょ
結局はね 誰か病気になっちゃったら
さっさとそれで自分信仰してるところに行って
まあなんとかして もうお祈りでもして
まあ治してほしいとか頼むことやらね
仕事なんかうまくいかないと
子供たちの勉強なんかうまくいかないと
どこか行ってお祓いしてもらったりとか
なんとかして まあそれでうまくいけば大変楽なんですね
ですから 私の話を聞くと
なんか怖い 怖い宗教ではないかと
もう自分で責任取れと言ってるんだから
と思うかもしれませんだけど
ちょっと理性を作ってください
使ってください 本当に助けてくれるんですか？と
皆様方が病気になったら
じゃあ一生懸命お祈りしてみてください
どんな神様でもいいんです
どんな仏様でも どんな仏像でもいいんです
それで病気治してくれるんだったらもう文句ないでしょ
でも人はお祈りするんだけど
病気治ったということはないんですね
結局は もし人が不幸 人が不幸を感じる時
お祈りして その不幸を乗り越えて幸福になります
なるならば この地球上の人類はみんな幸福なんです
なぜならば 共産主義の人々以外は宗教という概念ない人間ほとんどないんですね
この共産主義の方々も隠れて隠れてなんとかなんとか祈りしたりしてるんだから
例えばソ連なんか崩壊した瞬間で
もうドーンと宗教運動を始めたんだから
やっぱり心の中でもあったんですね
抑えていただけで 法律的に
法律的に自由になった途端
もう表に出るんです ですから
宗教ない人っていうのはもうほとんどいないんです
そこで人が不幸になればなるほど
宗教に対する興味が強烈になるんです
大体それは事実でしょ
世界の すごい抜群な幸福な人々なんかは
もうものすごい成功している知識人とかね
まあもう稀なね 天才みたいな人々は何人かがいるかもしれません
もう信仰なんか要りませんという人は
でも人は不幸になってくると
宗教というものはいわゆる祈り対象が必要になってくるんですね
そこにすごい矛盾があるんですね
もしお祈りして頼ったところで
人は幸福になるということが正しければ
地球上の人類はみんな幸福に満たされて満ち溢れているかもしれません
でも 事実として見ると違うんですね
ですから 仏教は理性使っちゃうんです
頭使っちゃうんです 本当のことを言うと
世の中の人々はお祈りする人に限って不幸なんでしょうし
物事もうこともう神も仏もあっち行けという感じでしょ
皆さんも同じでしょうね
物事はすごくうまくいくと
仕事はうまくいくわ 家庭は問題は何もないわ
子供たちはよく勉強するわ
もう言うこと聞いてくれ
それだったら神様というのはあっち行きなさいと
うるさいんだという感じで生きてるんではないんですか
そこで子供はなんか不良に走ったり
勉強しなくなったり 登校拒否したり
仕事は会社の仕事は何かうまくいかないとか
いろいろ不幸な出来事に事故を起こしたりとかあっちゃうと
あちこち片っ端から神社回りするんですね
八十八か所お参りしたりするんでしょ
ですから そこも事実なんですね
そういうことで 頼っても救ってくれないということを我々は統計学的に言うんです
仏教では ただ東京に至っても助けてくれないと
例えば万人の人が神様にお祈りするところで
一人ぐらい何かうまくいったと
やっぱり神様がいるんだというよりは
やっぱり九千九百九十九人の人々のお祈りを聞いてくれなかったんだから
割り当ては同じくないんですね
ですから その人間のこの弱みを捨ててほしいっていうのは釈迦様メッセージなんですね
何かあったらすぐ弱みでもう何とかしてくれませんかとか
なんとかなんて追い払いでもしてくれませんかとかね
言って走り回っちゃう
で そこへお釈迦様は結構ケチをつけちゃうんですね
人間がすごく不安で 恐怖感に覆われて
無知で いわゆる知恵がなくて
物事の理解できなくて
あっちこっちいろんなものにものを頼りにするんだと
インドではそれはものすごくあったんです
木を拝むはもう岩を拝むは
山を拝むは 川を拝むは
切りがないでしょうに
狐さん拝むは カエルさん拝むはもう
何でもいいんですよ もうたまに私は一回ある女性の方にもらったんですけど
電車で急に人が来て ちょっと話して
これ大事な石ですから
あげますと あなたに どういうこと？大事だって
自分が富士山を登って
頂上で朝日の出を見て
その時はこの石を拾ってきて
それを大事にお守りとして持っているんだと
で 本人にとってすごい大事なものだから
ありがとうございますと私は大事にもらったんだけど
まあ僕にとっては富士山の頂上の石ということ興味があるんです
これで私を助けてくれるということは全然信じないんですね
それよりはもう飼っている犬猫の方が吠えてくれるし
その時私の部屋に犬猫がいたんだけど
私は朝寝坊なんかしちゃったらすぐ起こしてくれるんです
だから猫は助けにはなっちゃうんですね
当時で研究してたんだから
勉強やめちゃったと言ってテレビつけちゃったら
すぐ猫に怒られるんです
もう数時間机の上に座って勉強していると
すごくそばに寝て まあ待ってるんですね
それで寂しくなく勉強できる
それで疲れてくるとやめますか？と
もうテレビつけちゃうんで
そしたら立ち上がってもう部屋から出て行っちゃう
僕は本当は猫とちょっと遊ぼうと思って
勉強やめちゃもう遊んでくれな逃げちゃう
ですから なるほど この人はこうやってるんじゃないかなと
ですから 助けになるんですね
それでも ですから 石ではまあなかなかどうかなと
でも人間もやっぱりそういう信仰っていうのはあるんですね
それは理性から見ると
合理的に見ると説明できない
だから信じるっていうのは宗教なんであって
説明したらバカバカらしいんだから
まあいいよと そんな話はあと置いとくな
釈迦さんの教えなんですね
そういう差があるんです
で ちょっと誤解しないように説明しますけど
例えばお祈りするのは全く 100%無効ですか？とかね
何かお守りあった方が全くダメですか？という大胆な話を言ってるわけでもないんです
僕らは文化は破壊しませんから
気持ちいいかもしれませんし
例えば子供が試験なんかに行く場合は
お母さんがね これはもうあなたに特別に買ったけど
お守りで持ってきなさいと言っちゃったら
まあもしかするとまあすごく気持ちが良くなる可能性はありますよ
それは心理学的に説明できるんです
残念ながら 持ってきたお札やお守りの力というよりは
そこに人間の心という愛情という心配してるんだと
応援してるんだと という安心感ですか
この不安 心が不安定な時
もう安心感を得られるんだから
安心したら何でもできるんだから
人間に 仏教ではそういう風に解釈するんですね
ですから 自分もきちんと守られているんだと
大丈夫だと自分に自己暗示かければ
いくらかは物事をうまくいっちゃうんです
そこで仏教で言うね 心理学的にそれだったら最初から自分で自信満々でいればいいでしょうと
ただそれだけのことなんですね
最初からもう自信満々でもうやればできるんだと
できないことはいくらやってもできないんだとという感じでいれば
実にお守りの効果がそこで効いてるんです
そういうすごく合理的なんですね
そこで仏教ではこの敏捷菩薩という言葉がございまして
敏捷っていうのは知識人という意味なんです
これは英訳するとエリートと訳するんですね
日本語でエリートという言葉がございますね
日本語でエリートというのは
ある一部のなんかカッコつけてる人間だけなんですけど
英語の辞書でエリートという言葉はすごく理性を使っていて
物事をちゃんと知識的に判断する人々っていう意味なんですね
ですから この教えは敏捷菩薩のためですと
エリートの人々のためですと
知識人のためですと お釈迦様はしっかりとおっしゃっているんです
そこでなんかちょっとトラブルを起こしますね
じゃあ頭が悪い人はどうしますか？と
そこはあまり心配しなくてもいいんです
なぜならば この頭がいいということは
勉強できるということで決まらないんです
この勉強なんか全くできなくても
ものすごい頭がいい人々がいるんです
人間というのは結構頭がいいんです
よっぽどこの 何と言いますか
精神的な障害を持っているとかね
全く知識的な障害とかね
そこまでにならない限りは
大体理性っていうのは人間にはあるんです
ですから あまり心配する必要はないんです
それからこの勉強ありますでしょ
あれ 頭が悪くなるだけなんです
良くならないんです 勉強すると
どんどん悪くなっちゃうんです
勉強っていうのは 人が考えた概念が頭の中に染み込むだけですからね
あれは染み込んで染み込んで
頭の自由な活動は衰えちゃうんですね
だから すごく勉強している人に限って物事を考えられないんですね
そういう欠点があるんです
例えば 我々に必要なのは
物事をいっぱい覚えている人じゃないんです
それは催し物としてはいいのかもしれませんだけどね
もういろんな物事を覚えてるんだとかね
それてきて なんかもう日本の歴史は
でもね 何でもこれはどういうことか
これはどういうことか聞くと
パッパッと答えるとかね
でもあの人はものにはならないんですね
ただ勉強しただけでは
会社にしたっても 社会にしたっても
必要なのは新しいインスピレーションのある人なんですね
いろんなことを新しいものを考え出して
インスピレーションがあって
世の中を良くする人々なんですね
勉強ばっかりしてる人じゃないんです
いわゆるある程度で革命的な人間なんですね
社会に必要なのは そういう人々は毎日我々の社会をいい方向へ回転させてくれるんです
言われる通りにやってくれるね
いい子たちっていうのは何の役にも立たないんです
ですから 皆さんもこの日本の最近あった現象なんですけど
なんでおかしいことをこんなに頭がいい子供たちがおかしいことをするんですかと悩んだりしていた覚えがあるでしょ
あれ 悩むことってまさにその通りなんです
親 親にいい子になってもらおうと思って言われる通りにやったんだから
ただ犬と同じなんですね
学校に行く 勉強する 大学に入る
先生言われる通りに勉強すると
それはね 犬もやってくれるんです
はい お座りと言ったら座ってくれる
それすごい超気持ちいいんです
はい お手と言ったら手を出してくれる
もう気持ちいいんです
自分の子供たちも 我々の次の世代も同じくなっちゃったら大変危険なんですね
日本の社会はそれはもう身に染みてもうご存知だと思います
そういう物事を言う通りにする人々っていうのは
社会には危険であるということ
ですから この支配者にもあります問題が
支配者たちが人を抑えるために
ものすごく独善的に お前方々はこういうふうにしなさいとマニュアル作って
テキスト作って このテキスト通りにやりなさいと規則いっぱい作って人を束縛しちゃうんですね
そうすると管理しやすいんですね
それも良くないんです
それで一般の人々は管理されちゃって
人間性を失っちゃうんです
それで社会はすごいダメージを受けるんです
そういう苦しみ その社会問題というのを我々はずっと味わってきたはずなんです
世界戦争を起こったのも
そういう独裁的な考え方
人々を支配するんだからなんです
日本の方々も覚えがあるんでしょうと思いますよ
徹底的に抑えられて 軍事的なね
軍事政権の時は何も自由はない
喋る自由もない それで大変な不幸になってしまっちゃうし
ドイツのヒトラーにしたっても
独善的にものすごくその人だけめちゃめちゃくちゃ喋って
で 一般の人々はただ奴隷扱いみたいにされて
みんな不幸にしてしまっちゃったんです
ですから 本当に才能あるリーダーっていうのは
人は支配しないんです
管理しないんです よって
会議に話し合って 何が一番我々にとっていいんですかと話し合って結論付けるんです
いわゆる徹底した民主主義なんです
そこで仏教はそれもあるんです
お釈迦様の教えっていうのは
徹底した民主主義なんです
すっごくそれ徹底しているんです
で あの また他の宗教と比べると
民主主義は通用しないんですね
例えば皆様ご存知のヒンドゥー教という宗教がございまして
インドの宗教ですね そのインドの九十パーセントぐらいの人々がヒンドゥー教を信じています
ヒンドゥー教ではカースト制度ということがあるんです
カーストっていうのっていうのは
家ですか 格ですか そういうものがありまして
このバラモンカーストというものがありまして
この神様が このバラモンの人々が宗教家として作っているんだと創造したんだと
そうすると ヒンドゥー教では宗教活動する聖職者たちがバラモンの家族で生まれる人々なんですね
そのバラモンの母親と父親に子供で生まれたら
もうその生まれた瞬間からもう聖職者なんですね
宗教者なんですね 他の人々はダメと
あんたのカーストは違うんだからと
そうすると人間平等という論理は成り立たないんですね
神様が差別を作ったんだと
だから文句言うなとヒンドゥー教で言ってるんです
それでお釈迦様はこの当時のバラモン教にものすごくもう鞭を打ったというか
ものすごいもう批判したんですね
あんた方何言ってるんですか？人間っていうのは同じではないかと
お釈迦様は差別を認めるんです
どういう差別かというと
例えば犬やら猫と人間と比べたら
あれ違いますと 鳥と動物見たら違いますよと
なぜならば生まれは違う
育ち方は違う 子供の育てる方法は違う
食べ物は違う 鳴き声が違う
体型が違うんだと 人間何が違いますかと
食べ物は同じで 子供は同じ
みんな妊娠する時間が同じで
生理同じではない なんとなく生物学的にお釈迦様は平等
すぐにお返事使っちゃうんです
生物学的な立場から見れば
人間は平等なんですね
そこで差がないんです
そこでまたお釈迦様はかすかに差が作るんです
人間の中では 人間の中では
でもこの泥棒する人々は泥棒だと
嘘を言う人は嘘つきだと
バラモン人じゃないんだと
人を騙す人はもう騙し屋であって
汚い人であって バラモン人じゃないんだと徹底的に言うんです
ですから バラモン人の人々はの中でもカーストの一部だから
ものすごいたくさんいるんです
だからその中でも泥棒する人はいるし
まあ他の女性を犯す人々もいるし
盗むもいたんですね 俺は
嘘つきもいるし 人を疑うもう詐欺やってる人々もいるし
でも生まれはバラモンだから我々は聖職者だと言っているんですね
お釈迦様 あんた方は何ですかと
ただの泥棒ではないかと
泥棒やってるんだけどというふうに非難してるんですね
ですから 仏教では このヒンドゥー教の社会で生まれたんだから
もう徹底した民主主義があるんです
宗教ではこれちょっと欠けてるんです
よく見てください 客観的に
選ばれてる人間がいるんですね
宗教では いるでしょ 選ばれていた人間だとか
まあ日本はそんなにきつい宗教ね
伝統的な文化ないんだから
あんまりわからないかもしれませんだけど
例えばヨーロッパに広がっている宗教なんかを見たら
やっぱりあの選ばれてる民族がいるという概念があるんですね
私は聖書を読んだ時はもうはっきりと言うんですね
聖書で自分がもうユダヤ人の救いのために来たんだと
別に我々は関係ないんです
そこであるユダヤ人でない人がイエス様のところに行って
あのなんか病気の人があのなんとか治して下さいと頼んだところで怒られちゃうんで
他の人々に あんたあっち行きなさいと
ただイエス様はもうちょっと待ってくださいと
まあその人はすごい信仰ありますから
その信仰によってその人はもう救われますんではないか
なんとかその似ているような言葉言って
あの日本の日本語の聖書どうなるかわかりませんだけど
僕はまあ違う言語で読みますから
一応その人の病気を治してあげるんですね
そこで それはそれでいいんだけど
イエス様が弟子たちに言ったことが気に入らない
気に入らないんですね
このあなた方は食卓でご飯食べる時
食卓から落ちるものは犬猫が食べてるのではないかと
そういうふうに他の人々も救われてもらっても別に悪くはないんだとイエス様が言うと
あのたとえが気に入らないんですね
イエス様は別に気に入らないわけじゃない
イエス様はやっぱりみんなに何かしてあげたかったことは感じますけど
あのたとえは何かとんでもないけしからんたとえなんですね
ということは ある選ばれてる人類が素晴らしいんであって
他の人々はまあなんかよそ者扱いされてるんですね
ですから やっぱり宗教の世界では
このすごい上下関係あるんです
で 他の宗教から例出すと大変申し訳ないんだけど
例えばこのキリスト教を信仰していると
信仰すると天国に行けるということを約束しているんですね
でも一人も神にはならないんですね
神様と神様の周りには天使たちとかね
12の弟子たちとか イエス様とかね
マリア様とか いろいろな方々を言うんです
そちらには絶対近寄らないんです
我々はまあその大勢 創造された人物で
卑小なもので まあまあなんとか天国通してご褒美もらうというぐらいのことなんですね
ですから この同じくなるということは全くないんです
そこで仏教 それは大乗仏教も同じなんですけど
徹底的に生命平等ということを徹底しているんですね
そのお釈迦様のその立場が
もう大乗仏教になってもそれほど変わってないんです
いわゆるお釈迦様がこう言うんです
で 私はこの修行方法で完全たる心を作ったんだと
完全な人になりましたと
すべての問題を解決しましたと
あなた方もこの方法でやれば全く同じくなるんだと
ですから 同じくなるんです
同じレベルに ですから
この仏教では 人のそういう性別は聞かない
生まれは聞かない 皮膚の色は聞かない
髪の毛はどんな色か 目はどんな色かとか
そういう差別はまるっきりなし
でも仏教は小さい宗教だから
世の中でそんな影響あるわけじゃないんです
世の中で巨大な影響を持っているイスラム教やらキリスト教やら
もう差別だらけなんです
イスラム教は民族差別はしませんだけど
男女差別はする キリスト教は徹底的に民族差別をする
で そういうことなんですね
仏教はそれをやらないんですね
人類ということで みんな同じです
肌の色はどうでもいいんです
貧しい家庭で生まれても
すごい豊かな家庭で生まれても
そんな気にしないそんなこと
そこでちょっとお釈迦様のこういうお話があるんで
お釈迦様が悟り開く前に夢を見たんだそうで
で まあそろそろ悟るだろうと
苦行をやめちゃって ただ朝ちょうどこれから実践しようと思って
ご飯も食べて その日は寝たでしょう
寝たら夢を見たんです
夢を 5つ見たんだけど
一つはこの東西南北から 4種類の色の鳥 4羽が飛んでくるんです
青いやら赤いやら もう色 4つですね
飛んできて お釈迦様の足のところに止まる
止まったらみんな真っ白く同じ色になっちゃう
この 4羽の鳥は そういう夢を見たんだと
それでお釈迦様まだ 悟ってないんだから
当時のヒンドゥー教の式だれによってその夢を解読してみるんですね
どういう解読かというと
自分はもし悟り開いたら
この４つのカーストの人々が私のところに来るんだと
インドでは４つカーストが４つありますから
バラモンカーストとワイシャヤ
シュードラとか３つありますけど
その４つのカーストの人々が来て
この仏道に入って同じくなるんだと
カーストは捨てるんだと
出家したらもう全く同じだと
で 今も我々その伝統を受け継いで出家すると名前捨てるんです
家の名前は全部捨てる
捨てて ただの法名という出家としての名前一つ
その長老が自分勝手にもう何か名前あんた今日からこの名前ですよと
いわゆるそれでもうずっと
だから自分の場合でも
自分の兄弟とか親戚以外名前知らないんで
誰も 私の出身地も全く知らない
スリランカの場合はこの何て言いますか
登録ありますね あの戸籍
そこまで変えるんです
登録しているのは 僕のパスポートにしたって
私の出家の名前でパスポート出ているんです
そこまでもう消すんで
でも人は誰か探せばすぐ探せますけど
まあ政府にちゃんといつ生まれたかとか
それちゃんと登録しているし
それは問題ないんだけど
でも誰も使わない 家柄は聞かない
すごく平等なんですね
ですから この仏教に信仰する人々っていうのは
結構気持ちよく仲良くやってるんです
お寺にはものすごく豊かな人々も来るし
もうご飯食べられないほど貧しい人々も来るんです
誰が来てもみんなそこで寺の中ではすごくお互いに仲良く平等にやってるんです
お互いに助け合ったりとかね
すごくこのいい雰囲気で
兄弟みたいな感じでやってはいるんです
ですから この仏教の一つの特色っていうのは
そういうことで 徹底した民主主義で
人間平等ということは
もう徹底的にもう頑固と
決まってるんです で だからといって人間はみんな事実上平等ということじゃないんです
我々の個人個人差があるんです
それもまた認める 個人の人格というものは
人間二人は同じじゃないんだと
それは人格の問題で 性格の問題で
ですから 性格を気をつけろと
汚い悪い性格だったら
もう社会人としてはもう良くないんだと
もう追い出されても構いませんと
社会から ですから とにかく頑張って立派な性格を作らなくちゃいけない
立派になりたければ という
仏教のまた他の宗教と違う特色なんですね
で またいっぱいありますけど
まああの まあ簡単なことだから
まあ思い立つたびに一つ一つ言いますけど
で あの この理性的な宗教だから
この理性使うんだから
かなり人間っていうのは自由になるんですね
で このそれからちょっとヨーロッパ的なこの定義なんですけど
このヨーロッパでも まあ英語では宗教というのはreligionと言うんですね religion
というのは このreというのはまた再びということで
あの 次の言葉がこの結びつく
束縛するっていう意味なんですね
神から逃げた人々は また神のところに繋げている
繋げておくと そういう意味で宗教と
漢字の宗教ってどういう意味か僕はあまりわかりませんだけどね
いわゆる超越した存在に自分がなんとかコネクションを取って
助けられて 頼って生活すると
超越した大きな傘があって
その中にいると この傘が宗教なんですね
というふうなこの解釈なんです
それはヨーロッパの宗教からそういう定義しているんですけどね
で それはインドでも同じなんですね
インドでもやっぱりこのすべてのものを作った
この神話ですか 何か基本的な元のエネルギーがあるんだと
で 我々はそこそれを目指して生きてなくちゃいけないということをインドの宗教でも言ってるんですね
ですから こういう定義でいきましょう
宗教っていうのは 自由に暴れ回ってる人々を何かに束縛されることが宗教であって
仏教ってどういうことかというと
束縛がされてる人々はみんな片っ端から自由にしちゃう
自由にしてあげる ということで
この信仰ということを仏教ではないんです
この言葉 ちょっと誤解するかもしれませんだけど
あのヒンドゥー語でこのバクティという言葉があるんです
これ英語で faith というんですね
まあ信仰って信仰ともう一つ
あの日本語の言葉あります
この信心でもない  えーと
なんか恐れ 神を恐れて神に信仰してるような
なんかそういうニュアンスの言葉があったような気がします
崇拝でもないんですけど
一応専門書なんか読んだところで見たんだけど
あまり漢字はわかりますけど
この読み方がわからないんだから覚えられない
まあ漢字見たら僕もすぐわかりますけどね
で まあそれは別に この
この faith という言葉では
このよくわかることで
この偉大なる存在に対して何となく恐れがあって
いわゆる恐怖ということではなくて
まあ崇拝的な恐れがあって
それに頼って もう自分を放棄して生活する気持ちなんですね
で あの 仏教から言えば
この まあだいたい浄土真宗とかは
まあそういうバクティですね
あの まあヒンドゥー教やらね
まあヨーロッパ的な神様という絶対的な存在信じている場合は
もうとにかく信じなさいということが出てきて
あなた方には偉大なる存在はわかるわけないでしょうと
ですから まあ信じるしか道がないでしょうと
頼るしか道がないでしょうと
そういうふうな気持ちがあって
これは特別な宗教批判じゃなくて
私は心の状態を説明しているんですね
それで 仏教はそこにちょっと恐れを感じるんです
どういうことかというと
言われる通りにする 例えば南無阿弥陀仏でもいいし
南無妙法蓮華経でもいいし
他の呪文でもいいし そればっかり唱えたりするとかね
あるいは他の宗教 他の宗教でもいいし
いわゆる通りにやっていると
人間は自分で何か考えて行動することはまあ置いておかなくちゃいけない
自分で判断することは置いておかなくちゃいけない
それは邪魔になっちゃうんですね
信仰の場合は 自分で考えて判断することは
ですから 組織的にも 例えばカトリック教の場合は
組織的に人間どう考えるべきかということは
バチカンでローマ法王が決めるんです
彼が決めたら その通りにみんな
信じるんですね で 最近になって進化論を信じるようになりましたから
ですから まあそういうふうなこと
別に一般の方々は別にカトリック教の方々は進化論を信じていたかもしれませんけど
でもやっぱり正式的には認めてなかったんですね
で カトリック教では離婚してはいけないんですね
でも離婚はしてますけど
いまだに正式的には認めてない
やっぱり離婚したらダメと
宗教に決まりはもう破ったということになっちゃうんです
ですから 本当に誠ある人は離婚しないはずなんですね
それは個人の問題で 本当に神を信仰しているかないかということは個人の問題だから
こちらちょっと概念だけ考えますけど
とにかくどんな宗教でも似ていることはあるんです
信じますというふうな感じで
宗教には大体あります
その信仰という概念は
形はそれぞれ違うかもしれません
例えばイスラム教の場合はすごい厳しいんですね
信仰というのは ものすごい恐ろしい
もう読んだだけでも恐ろしくなるほど
もうすごく怖い信仰なんですね
キリスト教の方はもっとおおらかで
そんなに怖い感じがしないし
で 今おっしゃったように
浄土真宗なんか見たら
もっと楽しく 気持ちよく
いい すごい明るい信仰
ものすごく明るいんです
浄土真宗は 信仰っていうのは所詮暗いんです
暗いんだけど 浄土真宗だけちょっと飛び出したらすごく明るいんですね
アミタ様に頼っているということは
すごい明るい気持ちで
とんでもなく明るいんです
まあそういういろいろ差があるんだけど
なんとか信仰というふうなものはあることは確かにあるんです
そこで仏教は理性的な宗教として見ると
自分で物事を判断することはいけないんですね
そうすると 信仰にはなんか出番がなくなっちゃうんです
出番がなくなっちゃうんだけど
その代わりに他の言葉があります
バッティの代わりに それはパーリ語ではサッダーというんです
それは日本訳では信と書くんですね
信だけ こう入れちゃ 省いて
信仰ではなくて信だけ書くんです
仏教専門用語の場合は信しか出てこないんですね
信仰というのは現代日本語で
このサッダーっていうのは信ですから同じではないかと
信と信仰何が違いますかと思うかもしれませんだけど
あの釈迦様の場合はこれを定義しているんですね
サッダーというのは この教えを徹底的に理解したところで
合理的に理性を持ってきちんと理解したところで納得いくんですね
あ なるほど あの納得した状態を信仰
信というんです そこまで疑っても構いません
ですから 納得しない場合は
もうそれを別に もうどんどん質問した方がいいんです
ですから 信ではなくて
現代日本語では確信なんですね
仏教にあるのは いわゆる確定したという確信
信仰の代わりに確信 ですから
釈迦さんの原始的な原宗教
元の教えを信じている人々は
結構確信というか もう気が強いんです
大体お数珠なんか持って
いろいろお守り持ったり
いろいろ念じたり ああだこうだするのはもうすごく少ないんですね
もうなんか堂々とこんな感じで生きてるんです
だからもう心の中ってものすごく確信しているんですね
それは可能なんですね
すごい違うところなんです
ですから この確信するために必要ですから
批判すること 反論すること
それをもう堂々堂々そう自由にやりなさいと
って言うんです 例えば
この聖書なんかをまず初めから神様を信じて読まなくちゃいけないんです
そうすると信じて読まないとわからないんですね
僕でも聖書を読んだ時は
ちゃんと偉大なる神様がいるということを仮定して
それから読んでいくと言っている言葉は全部理解できるんです
そうでないと理解できない
で 神様についていろいろ質問してはいけないんですね
それはものすごい良くないことで
イスラム教でも同じことで
ある人が悪魔のなんとかという本を書いてあって
国際的に問題を起こしたでしょうね
そういう自由はないんです
ルシディですか そこで日本の教授がそれを日本語訳したんですね
筑波大学の どうなったんですか？殺されたんですね
どれほど怖いかと それでルシディさんも生きていられないんだから
また他の本を書いて もうあれは間違ってるんだと
で なんとなく命拾いしたんです
批判してはいけないんです
言われる通りにしなさい
それだけ で あのイスラム教の中でもいるんですよ
やっぱり見たらこれおかしいなと感じるとこは
あのパキスタンなんですけど
パキスタンにいたこのアリ・ブットという大統領がいたんですね
かなり自由な人で すごく立派な政治家でしたし
ものすごい立派な人なんですね
で このただのイスラム原理主義だけでね
人々を苦しめるんじゃなくて
自由に国を開放して みんなもう楽をしてあげたかったんですね
そこでイスラムの原理主義の人々はすごく怒ってクーデターを起こしちゃって
あの その人を殺しちゃったんですね
で 国際的に殺す 殺してはいけないと言ったんです
どんな国もここにもいたんです
それからこのあれは この昔のイギリスの植民地の国々だから
そちらのこのコモンウェルスという国のほうの国々の集まりがあるんです
コモンウェルス国々という
その国々の中でも みんな一致で
その人を殺すなと 別に何も悪事をしてないんだから
言ったんだけど 殺しちゃったんですね
そこで言うのは もう彼がもうちゃんとイスラム教で言ってる通りに生活してないんだ
酒飲んでるんだと まあ言い訳だけですけどね
それでみんな一般の人々が
またそんな話はこういう公の場で言ってはいけないんだけどね
まあまあ それでまあそうですねと
悪魔ですよと だから殺してもいいという風になっちゃうでしょうと思いますよ
イランの場合も イランの友達がね
やっぱりいろいろそういう問題がね
内緒でものすごい秘密として言ってはくれるんですね
でもその人々には何も自由に喋ってはいけないんですね
それはその宗教の聖書でそう決まってるんだから
ですから そこを私は悪口言ってるわけではなくて
やっぱり偉大なる超一流な存在があるならば
そこに悪口言ったり批判したりするのは
それはけしからんなことでしょうに
それは当たり前のことに
ですから それは神を信じるならばの話なんですね
ですから 神様がいるかいないかは確かめてはいけないんです
いわゆる疑いはダメなんです
という特色はあるんです
そこで仏教になってくると
お釈迦様は阿羅漢でこう言うんです
私は悟り開きましたと公で言ってるんだと
煩悩は完全に無くせましたと
解脱はしましたと 公にみんなに言ってるんだと
でもあなた方は人の心を読めないでしょ
あんた方には私の心は読めない
ですから疑ってみてくださいと
自分のこと すごい違うんじゃないんですか
お釈迦様自分で言うんです
私のこと疑ってみなさいと
悟ってるんだから 悟ってるんだとおっしゃってるんだから
はい そうですよと信じるんじゃなくて
あんた方 私のことを疑いなさい
だから宗教おっしゃってる方が自分のことを疑いなさいというのは
人類の中でお釈迦様だけ
たった一人 お釈迦様だけなんです
で どういう風に言っちゃいますかというと
あの なんて言いますか
探しなさいと 探求しなさいと
この人は悟ってるんだと言っている
解脱を体験しているんだと言っている
でも私はこの人の心の状態はわからない
ですから これ本当かないかと
私は徹底的に宗教しますと
そこをお釈迦様はみんな仏教を勉強する方々から
何て言いますか 欲しかった一つの立場なんですね
はい わかりましたとかね
まあじゃないんです そこ違うでしょ
まあ釈迦様の教えでは
で その場合をお釈迦様こう言うんですね
そこでこの疑ってる比丘が出家
これこれお坊さんたちに言ったんです
普通の人ではなくて お釈迦様のところに弟子入りして出家してる人に言うんです
あんた方は私のことを疑いなさいと
もう疑うってことないでしょうに
出家してるんだから 体の行動
私の喋り方 考え方 片っ端から探しみなさいと
そうすると あなた方にも煩悩ある人はこういう行動はしないだろうと
煩悩ある人はこういう言葉を喋れないでしょうと
煩悩ある人はこういう考え方はしないだろうと
あなた方には明確に見えるはずです
それで初めてこのサッダ
確信が生まれるんだ ですから
このあの普通の宗教とかと比較すると
宗教はまず信仰から始まる
仏教では信仰は後からついてくるものなんです
信仰というならば ものすごく勉強していろいろ試してみたところで納得いく
ですから 最初からあるものじゃないんです
それからもう一つ 一般的に宗教っていうのは
この死後のことを言ってるんですね
人は死んだ後のために教えてるんですね
まあ大体現世利益もおっしゃってますけど
やっぱりそれはメインの目的じゃないんですね
人は亡くなったところで
まあ天国に行くか あるいはどこか行くか
そういう幸福な成仏するかどっちか
その幸福な目的のために宗教あるんですね
今日 現代 あの世間で生きてる仏教にしたっても同じことで
葬式は仏教であって 結婚式は教会でやると
同じ人が ですから この
死後で成仏するというか
天国に行くとか まあどっちかでもいいんだけど
そこはまあ宗教の仕事だとというんですね
そこで理性ある人からの立場から見れば
問題になるんです 例えばたくさん宗教あるでしょ
このいろんな宗教で死後の目的は違うんです
同じじゃないんです で
結構違うんです 同じかないかわからないんです
で キリスト教から見れば
なんとなくまあ天国みたいなね
考え方があります そこに行くんだとかね
ヒンドゥー教だったら人間は生まれ変わっちゃうんですね
そこでやがてあの瞑想なんかして
悟りみたいな こんな弁賀一貫体験をして
この神だと一体にならなくちゃいけないんですね
それがヒンドゥー教の教え
あるいは仏教になったら
またいろいろあるかもしれません
極楽浄土に生まれ変わると
そこでもう話法を聞いて悟りますとかね
そこでこのちょっとした問題が生まれるんですね
どうやって確かめますかと
じゃあヒンドゥー教の輪廻一如は正しいか
キリスト教の天国に生まれることは正しいかと
確かめる方法はありませんね
キリスト教を信じて 真面目に信仰して
死ぬまでキリスト教でいなくちゃダメし
ヒンドゥー教に浸っても
それを徹底的に修行してヨーガをやって
その悟りと解脱しなくちゃダメなんですね
確かめる方法がないんです
それまた死後だから そうすると
ちょっと理性ある人にとってはなんか分からないんですね
選択できないんですね
そこで仏教の特色が出てくるんです
またお釈迦様の教えが
今ここで確かめなきゃダメだと
正しいか ないか ですから
お釈迦様の教えは全部確かめられるものなんです
解脱する やってみれば
もうああなるほどとわかるんです
そこに時間かからないんだと
死ぬまで待たなくてもいいんですね
そこはお釈迦様がずっとそれだけがお釈迦様の特色として持っていたの
私が言うことはもう正しいかないかと
あなた方にはすぐ確かめることができるんだと
それでお釈迦様だけではなくて
大勢の人々がその修行によってお釈迦様と同じ悟りを開いたんだから
すごいたくさん 一人二人のところじゃないんです
もう全部仕事終わったという
解脱したと で そういうこの今ここで確かめられる
という特色が根本仏教ではあるんです
まあそこにあの ちょっとまあ
余計な話かもしれませんだけど
あの なんとなくまたそんな人間に
みんなに簡単に解脱なんて得られますかとかね
まあ疑う可能性はありますけど
それを疑っても構いませんだけど
で じゃあ解脱は体現できないと
我々はまあ一応置いておきましょう
我々はそんな暇がないんだと
それに浸っても お釈迦様がおっしゃっていることは実行してみてくださいと
実行してみたら 確実にその通りに行っちゃうんです
解脱を得なくたっていい
他の目的でもちゃんと実行できるんです
それにもう一つちょっとしたストーリーがあるんです
お釈迦様のところにある人が出家したんです
出家したのは この現代人と同じくこの神通力
超能力好きで で その人が宗教というのは超能力だと思ってたんです
でお釈迦様にはものすごい超能力あるという噂があったんですね
で いろんな他のところ行ってみたって
先生に誰は持ってない
そこでみんな言うんです
そんなこと能力っていうのは
お釈迦様には抜群にあるんだと
じゃあそっち弟子入りしますと
で 弟子入りしたんですね
弟子の目的はとにかく超能力
そこでお釈迦様から見れば
まあくっだらない弟子だからね
あまり相手にしなかったんですね
相手にしなかったんだけど
出家したらちゃんと面倒見てあげるし
それは問題ないんです
そこでこの人はもうお釈迦様にちゃんとお礼をして
まあこれから修行しますということで
まあ修行を励んだんですね
励ましてみたところで
彼にはある超能力つけちゃったんですね
それは天眼という仏教用語で言いますけど
この特別な目が開いたんですね
いわゆる人間の肉眼では見えないいろんな存在というか
神々というかね 見えるんです
そこで その人は瞑想の体験で
その超能力というか 仏教で神通力と言うんですけどね
で それによって この人間より高度なレベルに生活している神々を見たんですね
見たところ すっごい大変素晴らしい神々を見たんです
自分の目で 見て その神々は踊ったり喋ったり
もう楽しく生活しているのは見たんです
見るんだけど テレビの音声切った
切ったような この英語でミュート言うんですけど
音声切ることできますね
映像だけ出て そんな感じで見れるのは見えるんだけど
みんな喋ったり歌ったり踊ったりするけど
音は聞こえないんです
要するにその能力はないんです
そこでその人はやっぱり音も聞きたいんだと
でお釈迦様に言うんですね
私は今神々は見えろんだと
でも神々はいろんな踊ったり歌ったりしてるんだけど
音は聞こえないんだと
その音を聞こえる方法を教えてくださいと
瞑想 お釈迦様は無視しちゃったんですね
全然教えてちょうだいと言っても
他の説法みんなに聞いて
まあそれで終わり で 無視されたことでものすごく腹が立ったんです
お釈迦様に対して すごく腹が立って
で せっかくを聞いたら教えてくれないんだと
で この人はこう解釈するんですね
もし私にもその能力付いちゃったら
私にもすごく超能力あるんだから
もし私もその方法を教えてもらってやったら
私にも天 あれは天耳ですか
音を聞く能力ですね で
それも付いちゃったら釈迦と同じくなるんだと
お釈迦様に情報できるんだから
それ嫉妬しているんだと
釈迦さんが私のこと同じくなるのは嫌で教えてくれないんだと思って
もう腹が立っちゃって
で もうずっといたんです
それでも まあいつか教えてくれるだろう
では教えてくれない で
その人はもう帰っちゃったんです
仏教やめて 帰って 帰っちゃって
違う宗教に入ったんですね
で またそちらもなんか超能力ある人なんですね
超能力あると言ってる人のところに行ったんですね
でお釈迦様は他の目的で言うんですね
あの人には能力はないんだと
まあちょっとこのものを見る能力つけたんだけど
それでは才能がないんだと
それは才能の問題だから
ですから やったってただの苦しいだけで
結果がなければまた同じ結果でしょうとね
結果なかれば腹が立って帰るんだと
どうせ解脱の目的じゃないんだから
仏教は用がないんだと
という話でしたけど そこでその人はお釈迦様に悪口を言うんです
どういう悪口かというと
釈迦さんの話はものすごく合理的で
すごい合理的で まあ理性的に
そういう理屈 まあ徹底的に噛み合わせ組み合わせて組み合わせて喋るんだと
別にそんな知恵とかね
悟りとかね そんなものあるわけじゃないんだと
あれただの合理的な話だけですよと
でも実行すれば結構効き目だけはあるんだと
そこは付け加えるんですね
でも実行するとまあ結構効くんだと
その教えは それをなんで付け加えるかというと
自分に経験あるんだから
自分がなんで仏教をやめたんですかって言い訳しなくちゃいけないでしょ
ですから 実行すればいくらかは経験
効き目があるんだと言って批判して歩くんですね
そこでお釈迦様にその話を続いたんですね
それからお釈迦様は完全にこういうふうに言うんですね
あのバカが全くバカって言葉使ってるんです
あのバカが私を批判しようとして褒めてるんだと
私を批判しようとして褒めてるんだと
だからバカでしか言えることないんだから
なぜならば この教えは実行すればその通りなるんだと
お釈迦様は決してただの合理的に喋ったわけじゃなくて
ちゃんと体験したものを喋って喋ったんであって
真実だから合理的だけなんですね
仏教は別に合理的っていうわけでもないんです
真実を喋ってるんだから合理的なんです
真実は非合理的ではないんです
でも合理的だからといって真実ではないんです
そのからくりもちょっとお分かりでしょうと思いますけどね
合理的なものは全部正しいわけじゃないんです
でも正しいものは合理的なんです
そういうわけで 仏教は合理的なんです
正しいことを教えてるんだから
で あの そこである ある宗教
インドにあった宗教はいくつかありまして
62種類あったんです
で その中でお釈迦様がこの簡単に否定している宗教いくつかあるんです
とっても簡単にもう全然もう工夫もしないで
一つはこの 人間が死んじゃったらそれで終わりだと
それで全部消えちゃうんだと
それきりのことだとという
この徹底した唯物論ですか
徹底した唯物論 それは否定するんですね
どういう立場というと
あの そこを持ってくると
人間は良くなろうとする努力がいらなくなっちゃうんですね
せいぜい生きている間のことだからなあ
どんな風にでも楽をしてね
食べて遊んで生きていればいいんですね
なぜ嘘ついてはいけないんですかね
それだったら なぜお金ない場合は人のお金を盗んではいけないんですかね
自分にはお金ないけど
人のものを盗んで自分が買い物をすると何かやるんですかと
何も悪くないんですね
死んじゃったらそれで終わりますから
で その人に捕まれたら逃げればいいでしょうし
バレなきゃいいでしょうし
唯物論というのはそういうものなんです
大体現代社会も唯物論なんですね
みんなこの共産主義にはすごく反対するんだけど
でも 家族は唯物論なんですね
ですから まあ生きる間ではとにかく頑張って
みんなバレなきゃ何でも誰でもひもじくするんですね
襲撃するわ ワイを取るわ
銀行のいろいろね まあごまかすわ
借金して逃げるわ いろんなことしてるんじゃないんですか
殺人まで犯してあげて
とにかく逃げよう逃げようと
逃げて逃げてできればもう大丈夫だと
ですから この唯物論っていうのはすごく危険なんですね
社会の幸福にはならないんですね
ですから 宗教としては生き方
その場合 宗教というのは生き方
生き方としてはやった方がいいと
危険だと それぐらいはお分かりになるでしょうと思いますね
で 全くダメな宗教というものもあるんです
お釈迦様は全くダメだと言っている宗教あります
それはすべては運命であって
定めであると すべては神に決められているんだと
全知全能の神様に創られて
人間はもう神様の計画通りにやるしかないんだと
人間には自由意志はないんだと
いわゆる徹底したこの絶対神の信仰なんですね
現代宗教はそれほど徹底してないんですけどね
このインドにあったんです
神を信じるある一部グループがいて
これを徹底的に信じているんです
どれほど徹底的に信じているかというと
すべては神は知っているんであって
神が計画立てているんであって
ですから我々は手を上げることしたっても
下げることにしたっても
喋ることにしたっても
黙っていることにしたっても
全部もう神様の計画通りにいっているものだと
というふうな教えなんですね
そうするとお釈迦様はこう聞くんですね
そうすると人は殺人をする
銀行強盗やる よこしまな行為をする
嘘をつく 悪口を言う 暴力を振るう
それも神様の計画でしょう
人は全然悪くないんだと
ですから 人はもう言い訳あるんですね
平気でなんか例えばアメリカにあるんですね
たまになんか人々はとにかくストレス溜まったりとか
神経質になったりとかわからないんだけど
機関銃なんか持ってきて
スーパーやらデパート行って撃ちまくっちゃうんですね
そこで 10人  15人というのもいきなり倒れて死んじゃうんです
そういう場合でも その人が捕まったら
えっ 私は裁く権限ではないんだと
なぜそれはそういうふうにしたかったんだからしただけであって
それは神様の計画ですよと言って言い訳する可能性あるんですね
ですから このすべてはそういうふうに運命であって
定めであって この固定しているんだと
人間の生き方っていうのは決まってるんだと言ったら
人間は何したってもいいんです
そうなってるんだから
そうなるようになってるんだから
そうすると宗教はそこで消えちゃうんですね
ですから そう言われて宗教でなくなっちゃうんだと
もう 1つ宗教がありまして
この行為に結果がないんだと
それはアクションとリアクションなの問題で
何かやったら我々は行動する
行動したら その行動によって結果ですか
報いがないんだとという教え
それも結構考えて言ってるんです
例えば 私はあの 何か重いものを持ってきて
このガラスを殴ると 殴ってガラスは割れる
それで終わりと で まあ行為が回転しているんですけど
別にそれに反応してリアクションがないんだとという宗教があったんです
日本語のことはわかりませんだけど
昔の言葉ではちゃんと専門用語があるんです
で そのアキレアワードと言いますけどもね
まあ言葉通りでいいんですけど
とにかくこの何か行動したら反応
反応というか結果が出てこないんだと
そんなことは宗教家が言うものじゃないんだと
宗教にならないんだと
お釈迦様はまたそれだけでも否定するんですね
それだったら人間何やったってもいいでしょうにと
人殺したっても もういいことしたっても
結局同じことではないかと
リアクションがないんだから
ということで その宗教も否定するんです
そういうふうにはいくつかあるんです
4つありまして  4つは宗教でなくなっちゃうんだと
もう4つ教えて そこはもうあまり満足できないんだと
1つあります このカルマ論言ってる宗教は我々の今の現世はもう全部もう過去のカルマで今こうなってるんだと
ですから カルマは語った時から消すしかないんだと
言って苦行を教える場合あるんですね
でもなんか納得いかないんですね
自分が全部過去のせいでこうなってるんですかとかね
そこで納得いかないし
どこまで自分の悪いカルマが消えたかもまたわからないんですね
いくら苦行したって これでカルマ全部消えましたという
ですから なんか苦行するだけであって
まあ納得いかないんだと
そういうふうに この他の宗教とか
釈迦様 自分の宗教に比べている場所が仏教がありますね
そういうところで釈迦様は何が宗教だと思っているかという定義が出ているわけです
前と言いました 申し上げましたから
あの 束縛することが宗教であるというヨーロッパ的な定義をね
その代わりにお釈迦様は違う定義があるんです
人間の生き方 決める どのように生きるべきかと
その我々の生き方を教えてくれる教えが宗教なんです
束縛ではないんです それをきちんと覚えておいてください
仏教も仏教も宗教なんです
でも定義が違う 私はどう生きるべきか
その質問に答えるのは宗教なんです
いわゆる何のために生きているんですかと
生きる目的は何ですかと
どのように生きていけば正しいんですかと
どのように生きていけば
人間として 生命として全うしますかと
その問題に答えるのは宗教であります
それだけはメモを書いてでも覚えておいた方がいいんです
そうすると皆様は必ず救われます
これはなんか安っぽい言葉なんですけど
抜群に心がもう楽になるんです
宗教っていうのは 我々はなぜ生きているんですか？どのように生きていればよろしいですか
どのようにすれば人生は全うしますか？その三つぐらいなんですね
それは教えてくれる場合は全部宗教です
ですから そこにこの あの
どのようにすれば人生全うしますか
だから 福博の皆様方はもう大変あの陰険だと思って
私はお話をさせていただいて
ますから よく哲学者になってその三つを考えてください
その三つに応えてくれる教えがあるならば
仏教であろうが他の宗教関係ない
それは宗教です そうそう
で 例えばこの神なんかはない
例えば仏教はない キリスト教は神様がいる
だから宗教ではないかというと
そうでもないんです キリスト教にしたっても
我々はどのように生きるべきかという一部を言ってるんですね
隣人を愛するべきですよとかね
いろいろ欲はあまり良くないとか
あの いろんな十戒もありますからね
いろんな生き方は決まってるんですね
で そこだけを仏教は宗教というふうに認めてあげる
イスラム教にしたっても
まあ全部決まってるんです
全部コーランで決まってるんです
もう何一つ人がやる必要はないんです
いわゆる あの 例えば離婚する場合をどのように離婚するべきか
そこまで書いてるんです
男 イスラムでは男性の方がもうすごい優位な立場にいるんだから
離婚したければ ただ書いて
あなたは今日から離婚しましたと
パスポートそれと離婚だと
それでもコーランで決まってるんで
その女性にはまあいくらかお金をあげなくちゃいけないとかね
それはどれぐらいかでまた決まっていて
それでイスラム教でも布施するんです
1年に一回 その 1年に一回布施する場合は
どれぐらいお金あげればいいかと
また額まで決まってるんです
2.5% 自分の全財産の
収入のじゃなくて 全財産の 2.5%寄付しなさいと
そこまで決まってるんですね
そこでラーマザンという 1ヶ月間断食するとかに
で いろいろあるんです
1日五回お祈りしなさいと
で そういうふうに生き方決まってるんですね
その生き方決まってるころでは
仏教から見れば宗教ですよと言えるんです
仏教 お釈迦様も我々にこの質問三つにはちゃんと答えているんです
その点 仏教は宗教です
でも 他の宗教とはまた違うところもあるんです
似ているところもあるんです
キリスト教と似ているところあるんです
イスラム教にも結構似ているところあるんです
結構ではなくて いくらかあるんです
ヒンドゥー教と比べると
もうかなり似ているところあるんです
例えばヨーガとか瞑想とかね
心の煩悩とか ヒンドゥー教でもジャイナ教でももうほとんど言葉さえ似てるんです
結構似てます ですから
だから私の話を聞いて
なんか他の宗教に対してすごい失礼なことを言ってるんだよとか
そういう筋合いではないんです
ただ これはもう知識的な分析だけのことで
ですから お釈迦様は宗教っていうのは
こんなえたい知らない概念を持ってきて人を脅すのではなくて
人々に生き方を教えてくださいと
そこで差がある宗教では
えたい知らない強烈した概念
形而上学的な概念を持ってきて
これだからこうしなさいと言うんですね
神様があなたを創ったんだから
神に従って生活しなさいと言う
どのようにすれば従えますかと
それだったら隣人を愛しなさいと言う
そこで仏教から見ると理屈は成り立ってない
仏教は証拠を出せということになってくるんですね
そこで仏教でも隣人だけではなくて
生命愛しなさいと言うんです
それをなぜそうですかと聞いたら
そうしたら幸福になるんだからと
生命憎んじゃったら不幸になるんだと
生命を愛したら 慈悲を実行すれば幸福になりますと
やってみればそうでしょうと
それだけ 神は入れなくなっちゃうんですね
形而上学的な超越した言葉が入れなくなっちゃうんですね
だから皆さんも試してみてください
今日家に帰ったら もう片っ端からありったけの悪口言ってみてください
家族のみんなに  悪口言ってぶん殴ったり
物を壊したりとかね やってみてください
結果はどうですかと あるいは言って
みんなに大変優しく 今日は勉強できますって
あんなみんなのおかげでありがとうございますとかね
こちらに来て勉強できるのはみんなのおかげですからね
それをちゃんと感謝して
どうですかね 私がいない時はもうどうですかとか
心配してあげたりとかね
ちゃんとご飯食べたんですかとか
人のことをちゃんと心配してみてください
どうなるんですかと ですから
仏教で言ってることは正真正銘なんですね
人に優しくすれば すぐその場で幸福を結果として返ってくる
人を憎んでみたら すぐその場で不幸を返ってくる
ですから お釈迦様には当たり前の話
そんなこと理論 理論する必要もないんです
慈悲を実践しなさいと
その差なんですね 仏教と他の宗教にあるのは
仏教でいうことは もうお釈迦様が言うんです
どんどん反論しなさいと言うんだけど
反論する余地がないんです
すっごいわかりやすく
まあそうでしょうと納得いっちゃうんです
ですから このとにかくこの形而上的な言葉は使わない
だから神通力 お釈迦様になったし
結構瞑想するとその場合あるんです
人々に でもあれは全然売り文句にしない
それはもう言うなと 人に
禁じられているんです
なぜならば 人々っていうのはすごい弱いものだから
なんかちょっとしておかしいことしちゃったら
すぐサーッとそこに群がっちゃうんですね
ちょっとした何かやったら
マジシャンみたいに そうすると
その人々の解脱の道が閉ざされてしまうんですね
ですから もしたまにお坊さんたちなんか修行しちゃうと
たまにいろいろ能力ついたりもする
経典なんか読むともうかなりお坊さんたちにあったんです
いろんな能力あったんだけど
誰一人もそれは使わない
誰にも言わない たまにお坊さん
友達同士で一緒に生活してるんです
一緒に生活してるんだけど
自分の同じ部屋を分けてるんだけど
この人が何か能力を持ってることをこのお坊さんが知らないぐらい
そういうこの人間の利屈と関係ないもの
それくらい秘密にしている
迷惑だから 社会に すごい迷惑なんです
で これ悪口になりますけど
言いたくはないんだけど
例えばこの我々現代社会で生きているんだから
我々の現代社会を見ると
そういうなんとなくちょっとしたね
超能力なんかありますよとかね
で なんとかどこかでなんとかの人のところに行ってお祈りしてもらったところで
あの もうなんか体の調子が良くなったよとかなんとかと言って
そういう超能力タイプに行っちゃうでしょ
そこで社会問題を起こしちゃうんですね
行く人はとことん頼らなくちゃいけない
いろいろとことんやらなくちゃいけない
それ 自分持ってるお金を全部取られちゃう
それは後から裁判に訴えちゃうんですね
自分のお金騙し取ったとかに
ですから この超能力とか何とかとかね
宗教の大事なものとして使うと
そこに宗教って成り立たないんですね
仏教ではない そんなこと使わない
ただ心清らかにすることだけ言ってるんです
いわゆる形而上学はないんです
あの人間好きですね 形而上学的なことは
例えば皆様方お読みになっているでしょうと思います
法華経なんか読んでみてください
なんか開けた途端 その瞬間からあれっと
あらゆる所から菩薩が来るは
神々が来るは もういろんな光は話すは
もうもう神通力 超能力だらけなんですね
結局そればっかりで 一体全体法華経は何を教えたがってるんですかともうわからなくなっちゃうんです
そのストーリーばっかりで
ストーリー ストーリー
ストーリー それはやっぱり文学作品で
人間はそういうのは好きなんですね
私も好きなんです こういうあの
いろんな神々のお話とか
このおとぎ話とか 今もこの年になっても
この子供にストーリーあるでしょ
いろいろ 見つけたら読むんです
お化けの話とか あれすごく気持ちいいんです
だからって それは本当だとね
皆さんもいろんなおとぎ話聞いて大きくなったでしょうに
シンデレラのお話とかね
別に悪いストーリーじゃないでしょ
シンデレラさんがね 亡くなったお母さんが出てきて
あのね かぼちゃでしたっけ
あれで何か作ってくれて
ネズミさんを馬にしてくれて
あのいろいろね 十二時前に帰ってくださいと
で おまじないをかけてくれたんで
それでまあもういい結婚できましたからね
それは別に悪いストーリーではないんです
悪いのはそれ本当と信じた時なんですね
本当にそういう風に魔法を使ってる誰かがいるんだと
なんで私のお母さんも亡くなったお母さん
そういう魔法を使ってくれないかと思っちゃったら
そこで人は病気になっちゃうんですね
あれ面白く読んで 舞台で子供たちがそれをね
シンデレラ物語やったりして楽しんでる部分は何も問題ないんです
それは文学作品として
まあ楽しむためのものであって
娯楽であって ですから
こんな年になってる私も
今もテレビだったらドラえもんやってるだったら見るんです
皆様見ないでしょ？私は見るんです
あれすごい好きなんです
で 皆様方 大人になったところで
私は大人だから こんなあの幼稚園のね
漫画なんか見ないよと思っちゃいますけど
私は違うんです 私はやっぱり見て楽しいことあるんですね
毎日バカなことやってるんだから
何やってももう無駄でしょ
ドラえもんが何やっても無駄で
あれ面白いんですね ですから
それはもう何でも出るでしょ
何でも道具出ますから
そこは絶対世の中でありえない話ですけど
我々の心の中で そこはずっとあるんですね
だから私にとってそれは面白いんです
人間の心の中で いつでも何でも怠けて便利な道具が必要になっちゃうんですね
どこにもドア必要になっちゃうんですね
そこでそこでいいメッセージあるんですよ
どこにもドアあっても
使い方を知らないバカはいつでも失敗するんだと
ですから のび太ですか
もういつでも失敗すると
結局はなかったことと同じ結果になっちゃうでしょ
ですから 決してあのドラえもんも子供たちだけの話じゃないと僕は思ってますよ
あれを書く人々は一応ストーリーはずっと決まってるんだけどね
そんなことはまああってもなかったことと同じですよと
同じこと仏教で言って
人為的な何かあってもなかったことと同じですよと
で なぜならば このいろんなこの宗教家やらね
まあ病気治すとかね 治療するとかありますけど
だからといって人々の病気は治りませんだからね
なぜかというと この宗教家っていうのは
仏教だけではなくて どんな宗教の人でも
あの そんなに悪い人間じゃないんです
たまに人々に何とか能力付いたりしてね
人々をなんとか病気でも治してあげようとか
いい気持ちで あの 本当に善意でやったりはするんです
でも治せないんですね
もしできるならば 人類みんなの病気治してくれるんです
この癌なんか治してくれるという
あの こういうあの神秘的ないろんなことをしてね
お祈りとかいろんなことをして治ってくれる場所あるでしょ
その人に聞けば あなたは何人かだけですかと
治してあげたいの あなたにお金をあげる人だけですかと聞けばすぐ答えると思いますよ
いいえ できればこの地球のみんなの癌を治してあげたいんだと
気持ちはあるんだけど
できないんです そこへ行く人々はみんな治るわけはないしね
たまに一人二人治ったかもしれませんし
それも治らなかったかもしれませんし
どこかわかりませんから
ですから ないと同じなんですね
今も癌には治療はないし
お祈りしたっても同じことなんですね
ですから この超能力なんかは
仏教ではまあ 初期仏教ではね
あんまり大事にしてないんですね
否定してないんです あの心のエネルギーだから
心が成長すると当然抜群な力が出てくるんです
それをまた仏教では合理的に言うんです
なぜならば 人間やってることはすべて心でやってるんだと
心をちょっとだけ大人にしてあげると
結構いいことをするんだと
それは証拠があるんです
皆様方 生まれた時 小さい時
思い出してください ものすごく遊びたかったでしょ
自由自在に わがままの本義で
何か母親父親何か買って欲しかったら
あれ買ってくれと それだけでしょ
で でも母も父もすごい厳しくて
それ買って欲しいというものを何でも買ってくるわけでもないし
食べたいというものを何でも食べさせるわけでもないし
もういろいろものことを教えちゃうんですね
ああしなさいこう それ嫌なんですね
嫌ですけど 自分がやるでしょうに
特に学校にいらっしゃったし
学校に行くのは別に気持ちいいものでもないし
嫌な勉強もしましたし
そこでどうなったかというと
我々のこのわがままな心をコントロールしちゃったんですね
自由自在にはならなかったんです
やりたくない勉強して
やりたくない稽古事をしたりとかね
学んだりとか で 守りたくないしきたりを守ったりとかね
私は皆様の心も本当に聞いてやったら
そんなに行儀よくしきたりよくいたくないと思いますよ
腹が立ったらこのやろうとかあーだこうとかね
まあ言っちゃえばすごい楽だと思いますけどね
でも言わないしね 怒ってもそこら辺はちょっと自分をコントロールして
もう気をつけて心をコントロールする
そこで我々は教育を受けるということの一つの心の修行なんですね
それをどうなってるんですか？人間が教育して教育を受けて
こういう奇跡的な世界を作ってるんですね
今の世界 あまり我々見慣れて慣れてもう当たり前だと思ってますけど
ちょっと 20年前と考えると奇跡なんですね
私は日本に来た時はもうコンピューターっていうのは大学の研究施設しかなかったんです
そこをまた特別な部屋に入れちゃって
普通の人には入りはできませんし
大変貴重なものでしたけど
そこでどんどんパソコンというね
パーソナルコンピューターというものができ
作り始めて で 私は一番最初に一つ買いましたけど
昔 で 買う前にもうすごいお金かかっちゃったんだから
何人かに相談したんです
みんなやめなさいやめなさいって
そんなことはもうあなた方が使うもんじゃないんだ
仏教の人々 それはもう科学系のそういう人々だけが使っているもので
あんたはよく何に使いますかとか
そう言われたんです 言われて
その時プログラムなかったんですよ
プログラムなかったんだけど
僕はいえ ちょっとだけ工夫してプログラムぐらい自分なりに組み込めばなんとかなるんじゃないかなと
言って 基本的なプログラムのやり方をもうお願いして教えてもらったんです
で 専門でやってる友達がいたんです
一人も教えてくれなかったんです
それで専門でない他の人にちょっと聞いたら
ちょっと教えてくれて
また東大のある先生が来て
2 3回基本的なことをちょっと教えてくれた
それで教えてもらって
それでわからないところはと
僕は友達に聞いたんです
もう教えてくれなかったんです
友達だから じゃああんた教えてくれなくても
私は一人でやりますと
言って まあ一人でいろいろいじってみたんだけど
今はどうですかね 今お子さんたちが料理を今日はどんな料理にしようかとコンピューターで CD じゃあそこから見るんだから
子供たちもインターネットにつなげているんだから
だからすごい もう  で 年以内の出来事でしょうに
すごくある日すごい面白いことがあったんです
それ最近ではなくてもう七
八年前で ある小さな子供が
僕はものすごく昔からよくコンピューター店によく行くんですから
そしたら子供 ある子供がこのなんとか上に立っちゃって
手が届かないんですね
コンピューターと 行ってこうこうやって
手でまあもうぶったりしてるんですね
もう何もわからないんだけど
いろんなものをテレビ画面出るんだから
で それ見て なんかなく楽しかったんですね
で これ未来に見えたんですね
今はこうやって何もわからなくていじってるんだけど
もうそろそろ誰でも使えるようになるんだと
やっぱりもう二年 三年でも子供たちも使えるようになってしまったしね
ですから それは人間の知識の軌跡なんですね
心をコントロールしたことの軌跡なんです
神通力なんで 超能力なんです
正真正銘の 今 大阪に行くってたった三時間さえあればいいでしょうに
江戸時代どうですかね
財産ももうみんなにあげて行かなくちゃいけない
途中で殺されるかもしれませんだから
ですから 江戸時代の人が今来ちゃったら
もうもう超能力だらけでどうしようもないでしょうね
ドアにね 行くとドアを自動的に開けてくれるし
そういうものはもう超能力なんです
普通の能力じゃないんだから
ですから お釈迦様はそこでそういうのを心を育てたからでしょう
さらに心を育てると さらに立派なことができるんだと
今は心が物質支配しているんだから
さらに心を育てると もっと徹底的に物質を支配することができるんです
物質を無視することさえできるのです
今 私は自分の国にいる親戚に喋りたければ喋りますよ
電話かければ でも物質を通して喋ってるんですね
でもそちらも一応超能力は働いてるんですね
衛星使ってちゃんとつなげますから
瞬時につなげますからね
二秒でもかからないんですね
電波つなげるために で
奇跡といえば奇跡で 神通力では神通力で
超能力で で さらに私は心が成長するならば
物質と関係なく喋ることもできるんです
物質を置いておいて 今支配してるでしょ
支配してるんだけど 半分支配されてるんですね
昔は物質に支配されっぱなしで
今は支配されていると同時に私たちも物質を支配している
もうちょっと心成長しちゃうと
物質はもう置いておいて上に行くことはできるんです
そこなんですね 仏教で言ってる神通力っていうのは
ですから まあ合理的なんです
あまり不思議なものではないんです
難しいんだけどね 結局修行は必要なんですし
欲を捨てなくちゃできないし
ですから この あの 本物の超能力者っていうのは欲がないんです
ですから 社会問題は起こりません
じゃあまあ時間になりましたけど
またいろいろいくつかのポイントは送りましたし
で あの そういう風にお釈迦様はの教え自体はいろいろな点で違う
すごく合理的であります
皆様は疑って本当かなという気持ちで勉強した方がいいんです
それですごい明るいんです
この宗教の定義だけをよく理解すると
かなり元気になるはずなんです
だからといって僕はいろんな宗教に対していろいろ悪口言ったんだけど
だからといって仏教というのはいい加減な教えではないんです
あなた方の心次第で あなた方の幸福か不幸かということを決めますから
すごく気をつけて生きることはちゃんと教えているんです
仏教で嘘をつくなと言っているのは
人にバレたら不幸になるんだからではないんです
嘘をつく心が弱いんです
恐怖感で覆われているんです
だから不幸なんです 人をいじめる
人を殺す 生命を殺す人はものすごく弱いんです
弱い人が殺すんです 強い人は相手を殺そうとしないんです
まあどうせ強いんだから
それを言います 動物の中で一番強いのはどんな動物ですか？ご存知ですか？一番体力があって力強いのはゾウなんですね
全然一匹も殺さないんです
他の動物 平気で歩くんです
ライオンがいようが 虎がいようが
サイがいようが 何のことなく自分でドーンとんと
まあ試しにちょっとあの鼻でちょっとぶん殴ってみようともしないんです
もしゾウさんが虎見たら邪魔だからどけと言ってね
まあ鼻で ぶん殴っちゃったらもう虎が終わりですよ
すごい力なんです ちっともやらないんです
ちっとも なぜならば自分が強いんだから
弱い者いじめません ね
弱い者いじめるのは弱い人で
ですから心が弱いんだったら幸福になるっこはないでしょうに
それから殺すのは怒りと恐怖感と
恐怖感 仏教で怒りと読むんです
殺されるんだからということで
やらなきゃやられるよと
それ 強烈な恐怖感なんです
でも しっかりした心を持って
例えば自分の家に泥棒が入って自分を殺そうとしてるんだと
なんのこと あんた あんた私を殺したいの？じゃあどうぞどうぞ
まあ殺してくださいと言ってみてください
殺すどころか泥棒もしないでもう帰るんです
怖くて 向こう側が でも我々は怖いんだから
そんなことは言えませんね
そんなことは言えません
ですから この悟った方々は
阿羅漢たちが殺す人が自分を殺そうとしてきたら
全然逃げないんです で
殺せませんし 殺された経験もない
歴史もない 殺されません
なぜならば怖くないんだから
死ぬのは全く ですから
この仏教では このなんで道徳を教えてますかというと
それはもうはっきりした正真正銘の教えで
不幸になるんだから 道徳が上がらなかったら神様に罰が当たるんだからじゃないんです
それ仏教でおかしいんです
神様がいて罰が当たると
これ神様が罪を犯していることになるでしょうに
かわいそうですね 神様ももう忙しくて人をやることを全部片っ端から計算して
あなたは地獄で あなたは天国だ
あんた 人を地獄に落とさせて殺しますたら
神様は罪を犯しているでしょうに
ですから ああいうのはまあまあわかりやすい
まあただのストーリーだけでね
あまりもう気にする必要ないんです
それじゃなくて 今自分私が悪いことしたら
私がすぐ見返りはいただきますからね
なんのことなく そこに神様がないのはものすごい素晴らしいと私は思いますよ
例えば人間の社会で殺人したら死刑にすると決めちゃうでしょ
そこでも僕はすごく心配なんですね
なぜ心配かというと それは法律的にでも人を殺すことなんですね
問題はこのある人が人を殺して
とんでもない悪いことをしたんですね
そこで法律という肩書きを持って
他の何も罪を犯さない人々がその人を殺す
殺して 自分たちも殺人の罪
人殺しの罪になっちゃうでしょ
なんで納得いかないんですね
だから処刑を実行する人がその人を殺さなくちゃいけないんでしょ
それはどうせ人殺しだから
そこで法律上では処 刑に決めた人には人権がない
名前のない番号だけ ただ生き物だけと
と それはただ人間作る法律だけであって
事実上ではその人の名前を消しちゃっても人は人でしょうに
誰かがその人を処刑しちゃうでしょうに
その人には関係ないでしょ
かわいそうじゃないんですかね
そこで じゃあ残された人々はどうするんですかと
なんかバカバカしい感情なんですけど
残された人はそれで殺人者が殺されたことで何か得られるんですかね？何も得られないんだから
許してあげた方がいいと
僕は仏教的にね あ あの人のまあそれぐらい寿命でしたと
まあ死んだものだから
まあしょうがないなと
と殺された場合はね もし何か二度とそんなことあれないようにという何かあるならば
それは別な話で そこで怒りを持っていちいち言ったっても意味がないかなと思いますよ
たとえたくさん人が殺した人はね
とにかく死刑にしてほしいとかね
みんな思ったりするでしょ
それは危ないんです 例えば二十人
四十人ぐらい人を殺したんだと
その人はもう危ない人で
もう警察に捕らわれて
裁判でも それ国民たち運動やってるでしょ
僕はあれに反対です なぜならば
ある人が悪いことをするんですけど
これは何も悪いことを背負うさせてない立派な人間も怒りを募って
自分も心汚くなってしまっちゃうんですね
ああ 殺されて殺してよかったとかね
職員になってよかったとか思ってはいけないんです
そういうことを我々は仏教を勉強するときちんと理解できるんです
どのようにすれば立派な心を育てますかと
立派な心あると 人間確実に立派になるんです
殺されようとしている人にだっても
何のことなく力強くやれる心があるならば殺されませんし
人を殺人は世の中にある
麻薬の問題はある それから子供の自殺の問題はある
いろいろあるでしょうね
そういうのに感情的にならないで
しっかりした知恵で行動するならば
問題何もないんですね
なんで子供たちが自殺するんですかね
すごい弱いでしょ 精神的に
あれは宗教ないんだからなんです
生き方が教えてないんだからなんです
宗教というのは この今
僕の定義の宗教なんです
このように生きていなさいと
しっかり納得いく道が教えてないんです
たまにバカなことを言うんですね
親に預かった体だから自殺するのはもったいないとか
なんとかとか それでは納得いきませんよ
そうじゃなくて あなた人間に生まれたんだから
人間で成功するのがあなたの生き方ではないかと
自殺するのは間抜けなものだと
それは逃げ道だと 死ぬことは誰にでも簡単にできるんだと
生きることでしょうと
問題というのは しっかりやりなさいと
学校でいじめたって それはどうったことないではないかと
みんな大人 みんないじめられたんだと
みんな自殺したらどうなるんですかと
怒ってあげた方が正しいなのに
そうはしないんですね
いろいろありますけど
とにかくそういう仏教と宗教はまずいろいろ違うところあるということだけ理解してください
回目から仏教の話に入りますので
どうもありがとうございました